the president-elect has chosen the first
top member of his new administration
that's his longtime adviser ron klain he
will become white house chief of staff
claim was the former vice president's
number one aide at the start of the
obama administration
at o'keefe is in wilmington delaware for
us covering the presidential transition
such as it is ed good morning to you uh
so what do you make of this pick for
chief of staff
well good morning tony mr biden is
prioritizing washington experience
and experience managing global health
crises as he continues to build out his
team
ron clayne has decades of experience
working alongside the president-elect
and in several democratic presidential
administrations
four months ago i made this video seen
here in this campaign video earlier this
year ron klain explains the biden plan
to tackle coronavirus
the biden plan starts with fixing
trump's testing fiasco
he makes sure that all americans have
access to regular
reliable and free testing picking claim
as his chief of staff
mr biden shows the emphasis his
administration plans to place on the
pandemic
clain served as the ebola response
coordinator during the 2014
outbreak claim earned praise across the
democratic party
senator elizabeth warren called him a
superb choice
congresswoman alexandria ocasio-cortez
called his pick
encouraging
[Music]
the president-elect honored veterans in
philadelphia wednesday and is expected
to announce
other top staff and cabinet posts in the
coming days
biden ally senator bernie sanders
expressed interest in serving as labor
secretary
if i had a portfolio that allowed me to
stand up and fight for working families
would i do it yes i would but president
trump still shows no signs of conceding
and the general services administration
responsible for overseeing the
transition
hasn't officially ascertained mr biden
as the winner
that means he isn't getting access to
the presidential daily intelligence
briefing
oklahoma republican senator james
lankford said he would push the
administration
if mr biden isn't given access to the
briefings by the end of the week
so regardless of the outcome of the
election whichever way that it goes
people can be ready for that actual task
meanwhile president trump made his own
veterans day stop at arlington national
cemetery
his first public appearance in nearly a
week
the president continues to falsely claim
he will win the election
and has been tweeting discredited claims
of vote fraud including this video of
elections officials
collecting ballots from a drop box in
los angeles county
the day after the election are you guys
official election guys
but the los angeles county registrar
tweeted they were legally cast
ballots collected and processed by
authorized elections officials
in accordance with the california
elections code
as as the president continues to mount
lawsuits joe biden's lead
continues to grow in georgia he's up by
14
000 votes the state is now set to begin
a hand recount of
every vote cast but it's not expected to
significantly affect the outcome anthony
ed thank you